Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Frau Pflig. Ich bin hier in die Dienstabende als Kind und stelle
ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankengeschichte. Aber so erst möchte ich wissen, wie Sie heißen.
Ich heiße Lisa Hillenkörter. Könnten Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, Lisa schreibt sich L-I-S-A, Lisa. Und der Nachnamen, Hillenkörter, A-I-L-L-E-N-K-Ö-T-T-E-R, Hillenkörter.
Frau Hillenkörter. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 42. 42. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 11. März 1983. Wie groß sind Sie? 1,73 m. Wie viel wiegen Sie? 68 kg.
Tut sich sich. So, Frau Hillenkörter. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beswerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr zwölf Stunden ganz starken Schwindel. So etwas habe ich noch nie
gehabt, so starken Schwindel. Ich kann nicht richtig stehen. Ich muss mich immer festhalten und habe
Angst, dass ich hinfalle. Ich kann auch gar nicht groß gehen. Also, es fällt mir sehr schwer.
Hatten Sie schon in die Hebchwerde? Das war das erste Mal. Das ist das erste Mal.
Seit ungefähr zwölf Stunden habe ich starken Schwindel, ja.
Haben Sie Popschimmersen? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder haben Sie schon mal Erbrochen? Ja, ich habe ziemlich starke Übelkeit.
Aber Erbrochen habe ich bisher nicht. Haben Sie noch weitere Lechwerde?
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck, dass ich auf dem rechten Ohr nicht mehr ganz so gut höre.
Ich habe da zwar auch einen Urgeräusch, einen Tinnitus. Den habe ich aber schon etwas länger, glaube ich.
Damit war ich auch schon mal bei einem Halsnasen Ohrenarzt und der sagte, ja, das ist ein Tinnitus.
Und bisher ist er immer so, ist er gekommen, war er nicht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob der Tinnitus sich jetzt verstärkt hat seit diesem starken Schwindel.
Aber der Tinnitus ist da und auf dem rechten Ohr höre ich auch nicht so gut.
Wann mal das? Ja, ich würde sagen vor sieben Monaten, sechs Monaten.
Haben Sie das Schwindel dann in jedem Ohr? Nein, habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Sind fühlen Sie sich immer schwindelig oder fühlen Sie sich manchmal besser?
Ja, ich würde sagen, der Schwindel ist andauernd.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttalpros oder Nachtschweiß? Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Vor zwei Wochen hatte ich für drei Tage, da hatte ich eine sehr starke Erkältung.
Da hatte ich drei Tage lang Fieber, aber dann habe ich mich davon gut erholt eigentlich.
War Ihnen schwarz vor der Augen? Nein, war mir nicht schwarz vor den Augen.
Ich habe zwar immer mit niedrigen Blutdruck zu tun, schon seit meiner Jugend, dass mir häufiger mal kurz schwindelig wurde,
aber dann wurde immer gesagt, das liegt an dem zu niedrigen Blutdruck.
Deswegen mache ich auch viel Sport und bemühe mich, dass mein Blutdruck wieder besser wird.
Ich massiere mit Bürstenmassage und alles. Es hat sich auch etwas gebessert, so ist das nicht.
Aber schwarz vor Augen ist mir bisher noch nie geworden.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit? Der ist gut.
Seitdem ich diesen starken Schwindel habe und die Übelkeit, da habe ich wenig Appetit.
Da habe ich auch wenig gegessen. Ich habe bemüht, etwas zu trinken, aber ich habe nur wenig gegessen.
Haben Sie in Leicester seit Abortusagen genommen?
Ich glaube, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten. Da hat sich nichts verändert.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder Wasserlasten?
Ja, mit dem Stuhlgang habe ich Probleme. Da habe ich auch eine Damerkrankung, eine chronische.
Im Augenblick ist das aber relativ gut. Das war schon mal viel schlimmer.
Da hatte ich häufig Durchfall, aber ich nehme auch Medikamente ein.
Die Damerkrankung sind schon diagnostiziert.
Ja, da bin ich bei einem Gastrointrologen in Behandlung.
Das ist eine Colitis Ulcerosa.
Da nehme ich auch Tabletten ein und einen Schaum.
Erinnert Sie sich, wie heißt die Tablette?
Die Tablette heißt Mesalazin.
Da nehme ich zurzeit 4 Stück ein, 4 pro Tag.
Ich nehme zurzeit einmal pro Tag auch Schaum ein, so Rektalschaum.
Haben Sie keine Probleme mit dem Wasserlasten?
Wasserlasten ist in Ordnung.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Manchmal kann ich das Wasser nicht so gut halten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nach meiner Schwangerschaft ist.
Das war allerdings vor 10 Jahren schon.
Wenn ich so stark husten muss oder etwas hebe,
kann es schon mal sein, dass etwas Urin abgeht.
Aber das ist nicht sehr störend und nicht sehr schlimm.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich ganz gut.
Aber wie gesagt, in der letzten Nacht mit dem Beschwerden,
mit dem Schwindel, im Kopf habe ich dich gut geschlafen.
Frau Wielenkötter, leiden Sie sich
vor Alkrankungen?
Ich habe einmal diese Colitis Ulcerosa.
Seit 15 Jahren habe ich die.
Seit 15 Jahren?
Seit 15 Jahren.
Das ist schon länger her.
Seit meiner Pubertät
habe ich eine chronische Schilddrösenentzündung.
Da heißt es immer, Ihre Schilddröse ist sehr klein.
Man kann sie im Ultraschall zwar sehen,
aber sie sieht aus wie eine chronische Schilddrösenentzündung.
Die Blutergebnisse sagen das auch.
Ich muss immer eine Tablette nehmen.
Muss das auch kontrollieren lassen?
Wie ist die Name der Medikament?
Das Medikament heißt Jodh Tyrox.
Wie ist die Dosero?
Dahinter steht 50 und dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Haben Sie noch weitere Voralkrankungen?
Nein, aber Schilddröse, dann die Colitis
und diese niedrig Blutdruck, mit dem ich zu tun habe.
Nein, das ist das so.
Nehmen Sie eine Medikamente gegen niedrige Bluthochdrücke.
Ich habe das früher mal probiert, aber das hat nichts geholfen.
Da kriege ich irgendwelche Nebenwirkung-Kopfschmerzen von.
Dann haben wir das nicht mehr weiter verfolgt.
Ich versuche, damit klarzukommen.
Wo denn Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind wurde ich am Blindarm operiert.
Dann hatte ich vor zehn Jahren einen Koffer.
Vor zwei Jahren hatte ich eine Operation an den Kampfadern.
Das hängt wahrscheinlich in der Familie.
Da haben viele Menschen, viele Angehörige
mit Kampfadern Probleme.
In meinem Beruf als Verkäuferin muss ich viel stehen.
Da habe ich die Kampfadern ausgebildet.
Die wurden vor zwei Jahren operiert.
Beide Beine?
Hatten Sie schon mal einen Unfall?
Nein, einen Unfall hatte ich nicht.
Im Krankenhaus war ich immer nur wegen der Operation.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein Medikament.
Außer Messerlesin, Rectalschaum und Ultrox.
Nein, ich habe nicht mit dem Medikament.
Nein, sonst nehme ich nichts ein.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Ich bin allergisch auf Nickel.
Da habe ich gemerkt, an Gürtelschnallen.
Da habe ich einen Exem bekommen.
Oder an einem Armband.
Das wurde auch getestet.
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Haben Sie etwas?
Nein, sonst ist mir keine Allergie bekannt.
Frau Helingkutfer,
würde ich gerne über Ihre Genussmitte gewonnen halten.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Das ist selten.
Ich trinke ein Glas Wein.
Aber das ist sehr unregelmäßig.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, ich wollte fragen, es fällt mir gerade ein.
Wie lange ist das jetzt her?
Im Herbst war das, seit Ende Oktober.
Ich habe eine Borreliose.
Ich habe 3 Wochen lang Doxycycline genommen.
Das ist ein Antibiotikum.
Das wurde dann aber schnell wieder besser.
Das war Ende Oktober.
Als nächstes spreche ich mir über Ihre Krankheit in Ihrer Familie.
Leiden Ihre Eltern oder Geschwister haben
irgendwelche Alkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist 72 Jahre alt.
Er hatte vor 10 Jahren eine Bypass-Operation.
Er wurde operiert, ich glaube 4.
Der Bypass hat er bekommen.
Er hat gut von profitiert.
Er hatte vor 2 Jahren eine schwere Gürtelrose.
Er ist in der Schmerztherapie.
Er hat eine schwere Neuralgie bekommen.
Er hat einen Schmerzsyndrom.
Er muss dann immer zum Schmerztherapie.
Die Mutter ist auch 72 Jahre alt.
Er hatte vor 3 Jahren eine schwere Entzündung.
Er hatte eine schwere Entzündung.
Er hatte eine Herzklappe.
Er wurde stark geschädigt.
Er hat eine Herzkammer und der Hauptschlachader weg.
Er wurde dann ausgewachsen.
Sie hat eine kunstliche Herzklappe.
Er hatte auch Cholitis, Ulzerosa.
Er hatte auch eine Schwester.
Er hatte auch ein Ulzerosa.
Er hatte meine Tante.
44 Jahre alt, die ist gesund. Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist 40 Jahre alt, der hatte vor einem
Jahr einen schweren Verkehrsunfall mit verschiedensten Verletzungen und lag lange im Krankenhaus und war
in der Reha, aber der hat sich immer noch nicht gut erholt, der ist immer noch krankgeschrieben.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Verkäuferin sind. Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Verkäuferin sind.
Ja, ich bin Verkäuferin in einer Bäckerei. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen und der Tochter, die ist ja
10 Jahre alt. Ist sie auch gesund? Ja, die ist gesund.
So Frau Helinköther, ich habe alle meine Fragen schon gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich? Ja, ich bin sehr verunsichert, weil mir eben so stark
schwindelig ist. Was kann denn so etwas auslösen? Was kann das sein?
Sie haben auch Probleme wieder mit ihrem Blutdruck. Deswegen resse ich
Ihre Blutdruck und auch nehme ich ein etwas Blut. Und führe ich eine körperliche
Unterlucht durch, dann kann ich etwas genaues sagen.
Okay, gut, das können wir so machen. Ja, das ist es.
Ja, Frau Helinköther, ich möchte noch etwas fragen.
Sind Sie so seit Schwanger sein?
Das glaube ich nicht. Mein Mann ist sterilisiert.
Ich verhüte direkt aber nicht, aber es ist sterilisiert und das ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass ich schwanger bin.
Haben Sie regelmäßige Monatsblutung? Ja, das ist regelmäßig.
Die waren nur etwas unregelmäßig seinerzeit, als die Kulitis mal
im Anfang sehr stark war, sehr schlimm war. Und da war die
nicht so unregelmäßig, aber das ist jetzt schon einige Jahre her.
Jetzt ist es regelmäßig und wie lange dauert es ungefähr?
4-5 Tage, ungefähr.
3-6 Tage, ich weiß es, es ist manchmal nie so ganz klar,
aber macht mir eigentlich keine Probleme.
Okay, danke.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen um einen Platz im Mathezimmer zu nehmen.
Dann rufe ich Sie wieder auf.
Okay, so können wir das machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit.
Und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die zugehört haben,
zugeschaut haben vielleicht noch Erginnzungsfragen.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Ja, können Sie stellen, gerne.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schwindel, ich kann es genau beschreiben.
Ist das Schwarzschwindel oder Drehschwindel?
Das ist mehr, habe ich den Ahnung, wie ein Drehschwindel.
Drehschwindel, okay.
Ja, danke.
Herzstolpern oder sowas habe ich nicht.
Das wurde da im Chat gefragt. Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Jetzt haben Sie kein Fieber, ne?
Nein, ich hatte vor 3 Wochen, ungefähr vor 2,5 Wochen,
hatte ich für 3 Tage Fieber.
Das war eine schwere Erkältung.
Da habe ich selber Ibuprofen genommen.
Ibuprofen 400, die kann man ja frei kaufen in der Apotheke.
Die habe ich glaube ich 5 Tage lang genommen, 3 am Tag.
Die Schwindelattacken, also wenn ich so mich aufsetze
und hinsetze oder wenn ich dann den Kopf drehe,
dann dauern die Attacken einige Sekunden bis Minuten.
Aber es bleibt immer noch ein Schwindel übrig.
Also der Schwindel verschwindet nie ganz.
Haben Sie ein Druckgefühl im Ohr?
Druckgefühl.
Ich habe nur das Gefühl, dass ich da schlechter höre.
Aber ein Druckgefühl habe ich nicht so.
Ja, ich glaube die Kollegin ist schon fertig.
Nicht sicher, aber ja.
Wir können gerne anfangen.
Ich muss zwischendurch mal husten.
Ich hoffe, da stört sie nicht.
Hallo, Herr Oberrads, ich habe eine neue Patientin,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Dafür haben Sie dafür viel Zeit.
Ich muss mal gerade etwas Wasser holen.
Es handelt sich um Frau Lisa Hildingkötter.
Sie ist 42 Jahre alt, 1,73 Meter groß und 68 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie klackte über seit ungefähr 12 Stunden vertigo
und nauseher.
Sie hat schon vor sechs bis sieben Monaten
Tinnitus und seitdem er klackte sie auch über Hypoakusis
im rechten Ohr.
Sie haben die Fragen von Fibar erbrochen
und wurde verneint.
Haben Sie das den Begriff von Erbrechen imesis?
Ich könnte sagen Fibar und imesis.
Aber machen Sie gut.
in Appetenz wegen Beschwerden und gelegentlich Durchfall wegen Qualitäts-Ulterra-Ulterose
und in Kontinenz seit 10 Jahren nach dem Schwangerschaft beim Kusten oder etwas Aufheben,
also eine Stress-Inkontinenz und in so einem Nivegen diese Beschwerden.
Besonders vor Erkrankungen seien folgende bekannt, seit 15 Jahren Qualitäts-Ulterosa,
dagegen nehmen sie 5-mal pro Tag und wegpeilschaum einmal pro Tag
und seit dem Jugendheit Theroiditis, chronische Theroiditis und dagegen nehmen sie
Ultrox 50 Milligramm morgens, die mit regelmäßig und ultra Schalkontrolle behandelt werden.
Ist die Patientin wegen der Qualitäts-Ulterosa irgendwo in Spezialbehandlung?
Sie war beim Gastroenterologen.
Sie ist in laufender Behandlung abrundung? Also sie ist da immer, permanent?
Ja.
Und auch arterielle Hypertorien.
Und am Ende Oktober hatte sie eine Sekenstil, eine Borreliose,
in Folge einen Sekenstil, die mit drei Wochen lang mit Doktsisikin behandelt worden sei.
Als Kind sei eine Appendectomie erfolgt und vor 10 Jahren eine Sexyosesarie
und vor zwei Jahren eine Operation gegen Beidseite gegen Beinwadiese.
Sie können sagen, es gibt den Begriff der Varizin-Exherese.
Das ist etwas schwierig. Sie können ruhig sagen eine Varizen-OP.
Eine Varizen-OP-Beidseite bei chronisch-venöser Insuffizienz.
Der Begriff der Varizin-Exherese ist etwas schwierig.
Exherese schreibt sich EXHRESE, aber sagen Sie ruhig, Varizen-OP.
Ja, das reicht.
Bei ihr ist eine Nickel-Allergie bekannt und sie äußert mit Erlangen.
Und sie ist nicht rauchig gelegentlich, trinke sie ein Glas Wein ungefähr einmal pro Woche.
Die Strobe kommt von Wurther Perl-Night.
In der Familie in Amamnese erlt gerade eine Beipass-OP, ein Beinfarter und eine gute Lose.
Was für eine Beipass-OP war das? Am Bein oder am Herz?
Am Herz wegen der Erklankung.
Wir können die Abgötzung, kennen Sie ACVB, Arterio Coronara Venosa Beipass, ACVB, ACVB-OP.
Oder Sie können auch sagen, eine Herz-Beipass-Coronara-Beipass-OP.
Bei der Mutter ist Endocarditis vor drei Jahren.
Und in Folge eine Tyrichospit-Weistransplantation.
Das letzte habe ich nicht verstanden, können Sie mir das noch mal sagen?
Also die Mutter hat Endocarditis.
Und Tyrichospit-Weistransplantation.
Die Tyrichospitalklappe befindet sich wo?
In der Aort zwischen Aorta und Herzkammer, in der linken Herzkammer.
Die linke Herzkammer zu Aorta ist die Aortenklappe.
Ah ja.
Ja, die Aortenklappe ist von der rechten Herzkammer in die Lunge.
Oder ist es nicht die Entschuldigung vom rechten Vorhof in die Herzkammer.
Rechte Herzkammer ist die Tyrichospitalklappe und das andere ist die Pulmonalklappe.
Da war ich jetzt frei.
Aber es handelt sich um die Aortenklappe.
Es wurde aufgrund einer schweren Endocarditis eine Aortenklappenersatz notwendig.
Die Mutter hat also eine Aortenklappe, eine künstliche.
Was hat die Mutter noch?
Oder der Vater?
Der Vater hatte noch etwas?
Ah ja.
Er hat vor zwei Jahren an butaloose in Gesicht gelitten.
Ja, kennen Sie den Fachbegriff?
Ich kann nicht edemären.
Herbst Zoster.
Der Vater hatte vor zwei Jahren einen schweren Herbst Zoster in Gesicht.
Und worunter leidet der Vater jetzt?
Jetzt leidet er unter Neuralgie.
Wir sagen dazu Postzosterneuralgie, Post danach, post, POST, Ostzosterneuralgie.
Und deswegen der Vater in schmerztherapeutischer Warnplung.
Auch eine kultusulsterase bei der Tante.
Sie hat einen Bruder, der 40 Jahre alt.
Und er hatte eine Verkehrschunzahl.
Aber jetzt hat er keine Beschwerden.
Sie hat auch noch eine gesunde Schwester.
Der Bruder hatte vor einem Jahr einen schweren Verkehrsunfall.
Mit vielen Verletzungen.
Wir können die Diagnose stellen.
Der Bruder hatte wohl vor einem Jahr ein Politrauma.
Darum geht es mir.
Politrauma.
Und er hat sich von diesem Unfall noch nicht erholt.
Er war lange im Krankenhaus und in der Reha.
Und ist immer noch krankgeschrieben.
Er hat sich noch nicht erholt.
Er ist schwer verletzt und ist noch immer nicht arbeitsfähig.
Was ist die Patientin vom Beruf?
Sie ist Verkäuferin in einer Bäckerei.
Sie hat einen Stehendeberuf.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Und hat eine 10-jährige gesunde Tochter.
Noch mal zu den Beschwerden der Patientin.
Gab es in der Vorgeschichte der Patientin andere Auffälligkeiten?
Hatte sie in den letzten Wochen einen Infekt?
Hatte sie einen Unfall?
Da ist etwas aufgetreten.
Vor 30 Wochen hatte sie Fieber.
Sie hat eine Erkenntung.
Dagegen haben sie 300 mg eignet.
Es hilft die Beschwerden.
Vor 6-7 Monaten hat sie auch die Netus im rechten Ohr.
Deswegen kann sie nicht so gut hören.
Sie hat Hypo-Kusis.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Die anamnästischen Angaben,
die Leute haben eine Hypotonie-Attacke.
Als differenzial diagnostisch kommen auch Tinnitus.
Schmerzen hat sie nicht.
Sie hat keine oberen Schmerzen.
Wir haben die Frage gestellt von X an alle.
Der Morbus Menier.
Kommt jetzt ins Spiel?
Ja, es kommt auch mit dem Bezwart.
Nicht, mit Schwindel, mit Tinnitus, mit Höherminderung.
So etwas kommt natürlich in Betracht dann die Neuronitis oder Neuritis vestibularis.
Das könnten Sie sehr relativ schnell auch sehen, wenn Sie die Patientin einmal lagern, zur Seite lagern, als Diagnostikum.
Man kann es später ja auch einsetzen als Therapeutikum, um Sie von diesem Lagrungsschwindel zu befreien.
Also, es kommen so ein bisschen diese Geschichten mit rein, eventuell in Verbindung mit der Borreliose,
eventuell in Verbindung mit dem Virusinfekt vor 2,5 Wochen.
Das kann durchaus eine Rolle spielen bei der Patientin.
Also, an eine Hypotone-Kreislauf-Disregulation glaube ich so eher nicht.
Das hält jetzt seit 12 Stunden an bei der Patientin und ist sehr schnell aufgetreten.
Und sowas hat sie noch nie gehabt.
Und sie kennt sich aus mit niedriger Blutdruck.
Sie weiß so ungefähr, was das für Beschwerden sind, wie sie sich dann vielleicht fühlt.
Ich glaube eher, es geht in die Richtung, dass es sich auf das Ohr eher fokussiert.
Richtung Montbus Menier, Neuritis, vestibularis in der Richtung.
Der Schwindel, wenn man mal nachguckt, ich habe das mal gemacht, jetzt heute Nachmittag,
um mich ein bisschen vorzubereiten, wenn man da mal schaut,
Differenzialdiagnose des Schwindels ist ein Riesenfeld.
Das ist riesig, was da alles in Betracht kommt, was es sein könnte.
Aber die häufigsten Dinge sind sicherlich oft der Menier oder die Neuritis vestibularis.
Von der Häufigkeit her.
Und dann gibt es natürlich seltenere Sachen.
Gut, es geht ja nicht darum, dass wir hier die richtige Diagnose stellen,
sondern dass sie versuchen, sich an die Diagnose anzunähern.
Da kommt das Begriff eines Apoplekses noch dazu.
Das kann es auch sein natürlich.
Das kann durchaus ein Apoplex sein.
Es erfolgt sicherlich jetzt eine eingehende erstmal körperliche Untersuchung.
Gegebenenfalls eine Fachuntersuchung im Bereich der HNO, der Neurologie
und dann wahrscheinlich auch eine Bildgebung des Kopfes.
Dass man da jetzt möglichst schnell hinterher ist,
gerade wenn jetzt die Verdachtdiagnose vielleicht eines Apoplexes auch kommt,
dass man jetzt dieses Zeitfenster, was zur Verfügung steht,
eventuell, das ist allerdings schon 12 Stunden her,
dass man da jetzt relativ schnell handelt.
Gut, ja, aber Sie haben das, denke ich, gut gelöst.
Ich habe bewusst zwischendurch Sie unterbrochen,
weil man läuft dann Gefahr, dass man das ursprüngliche Thema,
was Sie befragen wollen, verlässt und dann sofort in was anders reingeht.
Das haben Sie aber nicht gemacht,
Sie haben durchaus wieder dann Ihre Fragen, die Sie stellen wollten, weitergestellt.
Das ist auch sehr wichtig, glaube ich,
weil das kann mal in der Prüfung durchaus sein,
dass der Prüfer dann sagt so, jetzt will ich etwas anders wissen
und dann haben Sie das Konzept verloren, aber das haben Sie nicht.
Haben Sie gut gelöst und auch Ihren kleinen Stress mit der Daten übertragen,
haben Sie sehr cool und sehr ruhig gemacht.
Alles gut.
Ja, wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfe?
Am 4. Juni.
Ja, wo? Welche Ärztekammer?
In Reutlingen, Baden-Württemberg.
In Reutlingen, alles klar.
Ist das Nordwürttemberg oder?
Südwürttemberg.
Südwürttemberg, ja, Nordwürttemberg,
weiß ich nicht, wer da zuständig ist.
Reutlingen, okay.
Gut, dann würde ich jetzt sagen,
wünsche Ihnen noch eine gute Vorbereitungszeit.
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl, dass Sie das gut hinkriegen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich werde aber mit Dr. Bundes noch schreiben,
wie wir das nächsten Donnerstag machen,
weil ich da um 18 Uhr sicherlich nicht kann.
Ich kann da erst später, aber das will ich mit ihm klären.
Ich organisiere das.
Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen allen einen schönen Abend.
Vielen Dank.
Tschüss.
Danke.